[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
ah
ben bravo bravo bravo vraiment savoir
qu'est-ce qui les bonzes et qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme ça va toi c'est
la balle on dirait qu'il a mis du
nutella sur lionel messi a décollé avec
des amis de la pâte à tartiner là j'ai
cru que c'était un morceau de pain genre
et j'ai cru ailleurs étonné un morceau
de pain de campagne à gaza après le boom
c'est vrai que ça part vite c'est comme
le travail
par une vitesse vous savez pas où je
suis très content de vous retrouver de
série aussi de nous mêmes a donc
aujourd'hui pour expliquer déjà aux
téléspectateurs l'indiquent c'est tout
ce que vous ne voyez pas la télé c'est
normal indique de la saison il a pendant
les pubs qu'on a les magnétos mais le
premier indique de la saison va se
concentrer aujourd'hui sur le pilote le
pilote une journée test avant la rentrée
pour lui cyril test un peu les nouveaux
chroniqueurs les nouvelles séquences
nouveau décor un pilote qui cette année
a duré quatre jours et demi les pilotes
les jeux les équipes étaient au bord du
gouffre mais vous verrez ça dans un
instant puisque d'abord cyril pas
cracher dessus
jeudi j'ai reçu j'ai dit il ya une fuite
sur le plateau
ça tombe bien il a jacuzzi dans la
bouche
de ouf non mais attends je t'explique
j'ai reçu un gros un gréement
alors je voulais tu sais que tu mettais
ça sur mon père oui j'étais chez
carglass en donner
j'ai pris une pièce de deux euros sur le
bras
c'est vrai j'ai pris même pris un petit
morceau de boulaq l'aria
tae-woo regarde même pas à la coincer
d'abord s'il est aujourd'hui pour des
millions d'élèves c'est la rentrée alors
qui dit rentrée dit photo kc vous savez
que l'indiquent a le bras long alors
vous cyril avant d'être un tricheur à
l'école vous l'avais dit avant d'être un
animateur un producteur un propriétaire
de 4,4 asile et la serre il s'est éteint
tout le monde voulait il est mignon
petit mutantès mais tout le monde veut
l'acheter tu reçois des messages dans
toute la journée qu'ils veulent deux ans
qu'ils vont acheter mon cas at elle
ajouté il n'est pas à vous non mais
c'est vrai je leur dis même sandrine
rousseau
j'aimerais bien vous l'achetez moi mais
j'ai ma dose énorme et c'est pas du tout
ce que tu crois je suis vraiment
inquiète
alors cyril vous étiez un enfant très
mignon est à vomir tout ça et j'ai reçu
quelques documents oui est ce que vous
avez envie de voir cyril oui
un élément aulas
ce côté
là et j'en ai une autre
les fonds levés les foules le flop du
foulard
doyen et un style ya un délire comme il
ya des clients de via l'app coût est
folle et alors capillairement il y avait
de très grands projets quand vous étiez
enfant parce que votre maman vous avez
pris même en photo juste avant votre
entrant est maintenant on a retrouvé la
photo juste avant d'aller à l'école
regarder
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que va devenir votre si
c'est ça la belle à la redingote chez me
faisait très chaud on vous donne une
redondance et la drogue
c'est quoi un camaïeu de blanc camaïeu
de blanc oui je ne sens pas mal voilées
ou pas c'est très mignon on doit rentrer
et en janvier parce que
j'habitais dans une crêperie guen
mais sans déconner j'habitais dans un
sauna non mais c'est quoi ça
c'est vrai mais sans déconner on dirait
que j'habitais
j'habitais dans un chalet
s'avérer veille énormément moi vous
souvenez pas non mémoire graphique exil
aux fans à l'époque où il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de moi ce très beau très beau
bois mais il tire il vous est très
mignon mais il est quand même temps de
parler du pilote il faut savoir que vous
avez fait donc trois pilotes c'est pas
ça que c'était très long et franchement
bravo si les parce que chaque année vous
gueulez sur le son vous buvez sur la
lumière vous gueulez sur les champs
gobalement et cette année et bien ce qui
est bien c'est que vous n'avez pas
changé vous avez gueule et surtout on va
voir ça dans un instant j'ai gagné oui
de l'égaler moi j'y connais il ya eu de
très belles choses il eut très belles
choses vous allez voir ça avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet dans cette
branche semble pas ça vous ressemblent
pas de cyril regardez ce qui s'est passé
pendant le pilote une journée riche en
rebondissements on a voulu vous raconter
toute l'histoire en bref
s'applique
aussi pas mal a vomi quatre fois les
photos
[Rires]
bref on a fait des pilotes pour préparer
la rentrée de tmb le premier a commencé
à 11h de avec une terrasse de braguette
on a pu voir qu'après deux mois de
vacances à bas étaient toujours
interdits et oblige 16 barreaux mais ça
reste le bénisse la qualité du tissu il
est prêt à assister à une démonstration
culturel de ses chroniqueurs télévision
pour passer le temps et une autre pour
comprendre le temps andré malraux andré
manoukian
pour des raisons qui lui incombent
cyrillois vous pécourt à ce premier
pilote allez on va passer au quart
d'heure médias et après je vais vous
aimez rire
jaune et moi
comme cyril est bon il laisse quand même
une chance à ses chroniqueurs de dire
quelque chose de sensé vous voyez
quelque chose à venir partout on me dit
vous vous taisez à tout jamais demandé
tu peux vous sucer signés bref c'était
le premier pilote à 15h le deuxième
pilote commence cette fois ce n'est pas
cyril aux commandes mais pas batman
et pour ce deuxième pilote syrie joue la
carte du franc jeu avec les nouveaux le
pilote qu'est ce ça va ya c'est à dire
que généralement nos pilotes on voit des
gens qu'on verra peu après
une amende force de baba c'est de mettre
tout le monde à l'aise tu peux dire au
public ce que tu fais
une longue histoire moi je suis un
autodidacte et même toi le cul quand
c'est aussi une occasion pour lui de
retrouver une ancienne connaissance et
nora a reconnu
[Rires]
c'était le deuxième pilote 17h le
troisième et dernier pilote commence
cyril est ravi de voir quelques anciens
paix a très souvent manqué il a
finalement manqué d'autres moins c'est
moi je vous ai manqué ou pas pado
cette nouvelle saison baba l'idée du
siècle de même le fmi la banque de
france n'aurait pas eu fait prendre tous
vos cachets je vais faire un point
commun tous les soirs et à la fin de
l'émission je vous dire combien vous
méritez les génies sont souvent des
tabacs autant dire que casta diva pas
gagné beaucoup
avant la fin cyril a parlé de sa passion
pour les barriques
ça devrait te dis dans un pot des
citrons
[Rires]
bref on a fait des pilotes avec baba
[Musique]
et bien sûr
manquer via l'onu a jugé personne ne le
croit mois six mois six mois si ça vous
est pris une petite banane oui j'en ai
pris déjà est déjà en prendre une
guitare mathieu robail cool parce que
pour ça ils l'ont fait une fois
l'antenne comme ça et j'en dracénois et
l'océan
mais la vraie gens nous voir bien père
espère là des projets ce que l'on
parlerait asie les chiens comme j'ai dit
trois pilotes trois pilotes un premier
donc avec un peu de chroniqueurs
historique et un petit peu de nouveaux
cas durée 1h26 c'était le matin ensuite
un autre en fin de journée ça c'était le
troisième de la bruyère 18 pareil avec
des chroniqueurs historique car nos
petits nouveaux mais en plein milieu
cyril et un deuxième pilote avec
quasiment que des nouvelles relations
regardez les recrues voilà alors vous
les verrez peut-être jamais s'il y en a
que pour certains mais lui à myriam el
helbaoui et il n'a pas duré 1h26 amalia
plein et la plante audi nice a bien sûr
là et on l'a déjà vu
bien sûr bien sûr et même temps elle
était assez les nouvelles recrues mais
ce pilote n'a pas duré 1h18 26 couverts
il a duré 34 minutes
les rétros qu'est ce qui s'passe oui ça
va vite parce que si les nouvelles
recrues bah c'est bien mais 34 minutes
quoi je m'emballe heck
pour cent de la messe
que dont vous parlez ils ont tous 2 3 4
15 voitures qui est qui et pourquoi jet
pourquoi nous devons la sortie mitchell
il a sorti le député il a senti le jet
il aurait pu sortir les canaris il aura
plus en tant qu est qu il faut les
comprendre que ça peut choquer quand je
peux comprendre que ça choque certaines
personnes que ça serait fausse et pour
certaines personnes leur père paternel
et maternel et que ça peut choquer moi
je suis moi je pense seulement ça ne me
choque pas c'est une photographe du
planning ferme pas vraiment son bail et
puis toi et ça a fait le buzz le
planning familial est une très mauvaise
image aujourd'hui ils ont quand même
d'autres choses à faire que communiquer
là dessus il ya quand même une réalité
biologique à une grosse si mal au cou
l'occurrence c'est fait pour choquer
c'est plus pour marquer les joueurs
n'existe plus qu'on peut être filles et
garçons
[Rires]
le regard
[Applaudissements]
e
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
il va j'ai voulu après bien entendu
non mais c'est vrai et puis y en a qui
vont venir giuly bien sûr quelque 110 m
haies qui sont des revenus qui vont
venir la malle face à nice à antony dans
tout ça vraiment oui oui
c'est vrai c'est pas nous qui te
convaincre bah oui mais j'avais donné à
lire on dirait et n'aura qu'un effet
patron incognito il
viendra aussi tout le monde devra t'on
diarra oui il
y en a qui étaient énormes au pied
arrêtés magnifique on s'est rendu compte
d'une chose c'est que il est bien
meilleur pilote congrès mais c'est ça et
tu as été bon mais pas au pilote ses
bases marque sn1 oui c'est fou mais
cette année les excellents dans les
pilotes soient les bonnes questions
pourquoi rebbah ma foi très bas ma
commande à ce que tu es
et tu me rend malade mais ben ammar ça
va la bouche ça va je dirais toujours
qu'on a l'impression que ta bouche est
posée contre une vitre c'est normal
c'est vrai sur des greens c'est vrai pas
bosser enfin alors on sait pas pourquoi
il s'est réveillé il s'est révélé au
pilote benjamin il était très heureux de
vous revoir ça crée une complicité
magnifique à l'écran mais du coup
copilote regarde
[Applaudissements]
regardez maca selick tous les types
portables j'ai rien fait à six fortes
algérien fait insupportable pour nous en
dire plus on ne peut plus te plairait
beauf que jamais
salif et jacques politi fera pas la
première voilà
la première du plaisir se paye qui
m'attend pas la première ma gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
désolé mcqueen sera pas la première
tu veux faire la deuxième bataille le
fera pas
[Applaudissements]
il a fait le kéké devant ma meuf way gcg
pas supporté il est persuadé que tout
les meubles le pechoux et que je vais
les meufs ouais bah oui croyez vraiment
un oui pour les bus sa meuf
ça m'a fait le bon choix de mots aussi
mignonne à la bomba écoute
et moi mes yeux mes
bras étaient pas direct
ok faut que j'appelle pas ça fait trois
tués est passé à près de cinq cent mille
euros
c'est pas une bonne genre à dabou jeudi
au public genre à la faute c'est rien au
monde je priais 500000 j'ai peur des 500
millions de gagner autant les points bas
des toits a donné une association n'est
pas fait pour jouer mais j'en ai une
belle association brésilienne et quoi
sauver benjamin sensation d'exister
[Rires]
rien ça va toi très bien
pu tiens ton roulant tu dis rien tu es
là
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je vais faire un jour il a
dormi à la maison mais est ce que
vraiment on va raconter sa
forme est là mais lochte avec mes
enfants je suis rentré dans sa jambe il
dormait j'ai mis mon tusson sonné
[Applaudissements]
à la
barre et des bas mais dans quelle
émission on n'est jamais sûr disent on
est ou
non mais oh my mac là non non mais c'est
pas assez pour le réveiller gentiment
grévistes c'est pour laver a fait ça
vraiment comme une grenouille c'est
qu'il est vraiment excellent
la bise ou corriger la vidéo ah oui et
non les enfants ont filmé à bien sûr
bouger la ville où j'ai des vidéos la
semaine prochaine c'est à dire que vous
avez dit à vos enfants venez on pas dans
la chambre de bonne on va le réveiller
tu sais que la fourniture esprits oui
c'est un projet fort hills ou glycémie
série comme sa rivale aux à
surmonter sur mon nez sa part chaîne
voudrait passera mal même je suis à
faire bah rien
[Rires]
vous apprendre pour vous habitez ou dans
un petit deux pièces à dormir chez vous
je reviendrai d'un goûter oui c'est ça
ils sont restés dehors
ça c'était rien tir il puisque il ya des
choses qui se sont passées aux pilotes
que les téléspectateurs ne devait pas
voir non mais oh tu en train de nous
flinguer mais qui pourtant voir quand
même oui puisque je suis comme un payer
pour ça ça s'appelle les interdits du
pilote ait
aucun souci de sont en plateau je vous
rappelle cyril est un très grand
producteur et là une solution à tout je
vais avec des micros je laisserais
traiter
l'avantagé du pilote c'est qu'on apprend
des choses beaucoup de choses notamment
sur les petits rats penchant
sur un jeu au pied mais
je tombe sur la chine
pourtant voir si
des rapprochements enfin pas pour tout
le monde
encore ça fait combien d'années après
tout quand même c'est un train fantôme
où ça
s'était bien que la famille tpc qui a
toujours cette très belle cohésion entre
les anciens et les petits nouveaux en
bref c'est vrai
avoir de grosse culotte et c'est pas
celle de daniel
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment aussi c'est le on a vu
tard et
de ta mère elle a changé c'est toujours
cool elle s'est équipée des livres
toujours des conseils de très grands
professionnels
pour tout ça sans déconner quand tu
gagnes une bastille et à tout cela il
faut que tu devrais il faut que tu
le pilote a été interrompue par le fils
de cyril pour une minute bienveillance
avec minutie sur la thème bien castaldi
toi
[Musique]
et on laisse le mot de la fin à baba qui
a toujours des dilemmes improbable
mois mais j'en mets sciages je suis loin
d'être pour ses idées moi je pense pas
qu'il a fait des ménages du week-end
il va sauver l'humanité va bien son
conte semaine armoyan miteux dégâts
alors toi
[Applaudissements]